welcome as as some of you know who come
to these events we often run a short
movie about long-term thinking before
these talks and this one's a bit of a
stretch you know normally we do lots of
time lapses and things like that but
this talk is about privacy and I just
saw this movie with basically a $2,000
home-built drone that made me rethink
privacy and I think it will for all of
you
enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
good evening I'm Stuart bran from the
long now foundation
I'm curious somebody here got here
through Electronic Frontier Foundation
the ffs bless your in its heart I've had
the honour of being one of the founding
directors of EF f back when I was going
through dramatic changes every six
months or so seems to have settled down
to major public service by now and so we
are happy to be co-sponsoring this
between the long now foundation and EF F
to bring Cory Doctorow here tonight you
may have cards that are both replacing
my introduction to glory and also their
space on the back for your questions
which you may want to write during the
event and send them out to people going
up and down the aisles they will come
down here to Alexander Rose who will get
the most embarrassing ones passed them
to me and I will bring them up in the
stage and hit Cory Doctorow with them
you'll notice there's not much room for
questions so short and legible in the
dark helps a lot talking about Corey I'm
basically a fanboy I have been reading
for the win and makers and brother and
because of those really got in touch
with dr. oh now he is a PFF fellow which
means he knows their secrets and he is
engaged one of the interesting things
about a person writing contemporary
science fiction which he does is not
only are you getting a journalistic
insight into things that are just
showing the tips of their ears
so makers came out in 2009 and basically
anticipated the entire maker movement
that's now going on and goes beyond that
to say what happens if the makers really
win you get the victory condition and
everybody can make what happens then
because things just keep rolling and
then a good science fiction writer and
a good political analyst will do that
kind of thinking and writing and take
you there and so as a consequence
usually when you know of writers
political agenda they get pretty
predictable and if you've read one book
you don't need to read another because
they're all the same story this is not
the case the Cory Doctorow he takes you
to the place with his journalistic depth
there is a political perspective that he
plays out and he takes you there it's a
very interesting way to do politics
he's not exactly telling stories tonight
he's going dead at it tonight
Cory Doctorow thanks folks so um this
talks a bit different than the talks
that I've given I'm a career activist
and so that means that generally
speaking the end of my talks are
supposed to end with a call to action
lucky for me I've got an easy one every
talk ins with you should join the FF you
should support e FF you should volunteer
for you FF you should still do that but
this talk doesn't end with a call to
action although those are all good
things to do because it's a it's a
slightly different kind of talk it's a
talk where I don't really know how to
solve the problem it's a talk about a
problem that I don't know yet how to
solve in the talk I will propose a
technology and I want to make it clear
that the technology I'm proposing is a
Gedanken experiment it's a thought
experiment not a serious proposal not
something that I think we should do but
something to give you the idea of what I
think we should do so with those two
caveats out of the way I want to talk to
you tonight about the coming civil war
over general-purpose computing so I gave
this talk late in 2011 at 2083 the Kaos
communications Congress in Berlin called
the coming war on general-purpose
computing in a nutshell the hypothesis
this talk was this computers in the
Internet are everywhere the world is
increasingly made of them we used to
have separate categories of devices we
had VCRs we had phones we had cars we
had washing machines and now these are
all just computers with different boxes
cars are computers we put our bodies
into 747s our
sub flying Solaris boxes with a bunch of
SCADA controllers hearing aids
pacemakers other computer are other
prostheses these are just computers we
put in our body this means that all of
the socio-political problems that crop
up in the future
are gonna have a computer in the middle
of them and that means that every time a
problem crops up from now on you're
gonna have a regulator saying what you
know the entertainment industry has been
saying for a while now make me a
computer that can run every program we
can compile except for this one program
that pisses me off and the problem is
that we don't know how to make the
general-purpose computer the Touring
complete computer that's turing-complete
minus one the computer that runs every
program except for the program that
scares someone we don't know how to make
a computer that will direct a
self-driving car to do all the programs
we can we can compile except for the
drag racing program or the 3d printer to
run all the programs we can compile
except the one that lets us print out an
ar-15 or the thing that allows us to
allows us to direct our bio scale
assemblers to print out restricted
compounds so we don't know how to make
computers that can run all the programs
we can compile except for the one that
pisses off a regulator or disrupts a
business model or a bets a criminal the
closest approximation we have for that
device as a computer with spyware on it
a computer that runs every program but
has another program lurking on it in in
secret that watches everything you do to
stop you from doing something that
upsets someone a computer that watches
everything you do and then if you do the
wrong thing it intercedes and says I
can't let you do that Dave a computer
that runs secret programs designed to be
hidden from the owner of the device
which the owner can't over override or
kill in other words a computer running
DRM now these computers are a bad idea
for at least two significant reasons the
first is of course that they won't solve
problems breaking DRM is not hard for
bad guys the copyright wars lesson is
that DRM is always broken with near
immediacy because DRM can only work if
the I can't let you do that Dave program
remains secret once the most
sophisticated attackers in the world
liberate that secret it becomes
available to everyone else in the world
now DRM the second reason is that DRM
has inherently weak security and makes
all security overall weaker you can't be
secure unless you can be certain about
what software is running on your
computer
designing the I can't let you do that
Dave facility into a computer it creates
the security vulnerability anyone who
hijacks the facility can do things to
your computer that it's designed not to
let you find out about much less
override and once government's solve
problems with DRM there's this perverse
incentive to make it illegal to tell
people things that might let them
undermine DRM things like this is how
the DRM works or here's a flaw in the
DRM that would let an attacker or
secretly watch you through your webcam
or listen through your microphone now
I've had lots of feedback since giving
this talk last year from various
distinguished computer scientists
technologists civil libertarians and
security researchers and I believe that
within those fields there is a broad
consensus that owners of computers all
other things being equal should be able
to control what runs on their computers
that the world is a better place when
owners are in charge of what's going on
in their computers now let's examine for
a moment what it would mean to be an
owner of a computer who's in charge of
your computer now most computers today
are fitted with these things trusted
platform modules or tpms now this is a
secure coprocessor mounted on the
motherboard of your computer the
specifications of TPMS are published and
there's this industry body that
certifies compliance with the
specifications to the extent that the
specification is a good one and the
industry body is diligent in upholding
it and enforcing its logo program it's
possible to be reasonably certain that
you've got a real functional TPM in your
computer and it faithfully implements
the specification but the TPMS are
secure in that they contain some secrets
they contain some cryptographic keys
among other things but they're also
secure in that they're designed to be
tamper evident if you try to extract the
keys from a TPM or change the TPM out or
gimmick the TPM in some way it's
supposed to be obvious to the user that
something's been done to her computer at
least if your
you know an average person and not like
a sophisticated you know spy agency so
one of the TPM threat models is that
crooks or governments or police forces
or some other adversary might try to
compromise your computer so the tamper
evidence lets you know if someone's done
something to your computer so that the
TPM is no longer doing its job another
TPM model is that remotely someone might
infect your computer with malicious
software and once your computer gets
infected with malicious software you're
in great trouble all of the sensors that
are attached to your computer the mic
the camera the accelerometer the
fingerprint montt reader the GPS and so
on might be switched on without your
knowledge and then that data can be
cached and sent to a bad guy or both all
the data on your computer the sensitive
files your stored passwords and web
history can be sent to a bad guy can be
erased or can be changed all the
keystrokes and your computers including
your password can be logged and all the
peripherals attached to your computer
can be covertly operated whether that's
a printer a scanner a 3d printer a
scatter controller a car the avionics
system so on and so forth or subtly
altered and additional peripherals that
may soon be connected to the computer
that's infected include your optic nerve
your cochlea the stumps of your legs and
so on so you get the idea that there's a
lot at stake here and knowing what's
going on in your computer and
controlling what's going on in your
computer now when your computer boots up
the TPM can ask its bootloader the thing
that boots up the operating system for
assigned hash of itself and verify that
the signature from the hash comes from
someone that the TPM trusts now once you
trust the bootloader to faithfully
perform its duties you can ask it to
check the operating system and then
check the ask the operating system to
check the programs you run and so on all
the way up to whatever it is you're
interacting with so that allows you to
be to some extent or for some for some
values or sure sure that you know what's
running on your computer
and then any program is running in
secret are running in secret because
they've managed to do so by some by
bootstrapping a flaw in the code and not
by inserting something malicious into
the code that's a
subtle difference but an important one
they're doing so because not because
your computer was designed to let them
hide themselves from you but because
they found a flaw in your computer's
design now this always reminds me of
this guy
Rene Descartes who starts off by saying
how can I know about the world I don't
know if my reason is true I don't know
if my sense is faithfully report to me
and you know some mental gymnastics and
he says all right I figured it out I
know now that I can trust my senses I've
done some logic work I trust my senses
and I trust and from there from that nub
of trust that I trust my senses and my
reason I can then work out a whole
scaffolding from wit that I can that I
can hang off of that nub of trust and on
that scaffolding I can stand as I
surveil the world and try to make sense
of it having that tiny nub of stable
certainty is important it's from what
it's the thing on which you can
construct the stable edifice now a TPM
can be a nub of stable certainty if it's
there it might reliably inform you about
the code running on your computer now
you may find it a bit weird to hear
someone like me talking warmly about
TPMS after all these are the
technologies that make it possible to
lock phones and tablets and consoles and
even some pcs so that they can't run the
software that their owners want to run
on them and when we talk about
jailbreaking we usually means subverting
a TPM why on earth would I ever want a
TPM in any computer that I owned
well the Devils in the details as with
everything important imagine for a
moment two different ways of thinking
about TPMS the first one we can call it
lockdown and in the lockdown world your
TPM comes with a set of signing keys
that it trusts and unless your
bootloader is signed by the parties
trusted by your TPM you can't run it and
since the bootloader determines what
operating systems you can run in the
operating systems determine what
software you can run your computer is
not under your control but now think for
a moment about certainty you tell your
TPM which keys you trust I trust EF F I
trust WikiLeaks and I trust you bun two
and it tells you whether or not the
bootloader is that it can find on your
hard drive have been signed by those
parties or you know or by you
and it can faithfully report the
signatures of any other bootloaders it
finds and it lets you make up your own
damn mind about who you trust you trust
yourself you trust other people you
trust no one
approximately speaking you can think of
these two scenarios as corresponding to
the way that ios and android work iOS
only lets you run the the operating
systems that apple trusts and then the
software that's built on top of them
whereas android lets you run software
that that you trust you can tick the
little box that says let me run someone
else's software but there's a critical
difference between what Android does and
what I'm talking about tonight because
Android lacks the facility to do that
little bit of crypto work to let you
know whether the software that you think
you're running is the software that
you're running it's freedom but it's not
certainty and a world where the
computers that we're talking about can
see and hear you where we insert our
bodies into them and we insert them into
our bodies knowing what you are doing
having certainty is a big deal which is
why I'm coming around to the idea of a
TPM assuming it's implemented in the
certainty mode and not in the lockdown
mode now if that's not immediately clear
think of it this way the war on
general-purpose computing is what you
get when the control freaks and
government and industry demand the
ability to remotely control your
computer the defenders against that
attack people like me are also control
freaks but we happen to believe that
device owners should have control over
their computers now both sides want
control but we differ on which side gets
control whose should be in control
control starts with knowledge if you
want to be sure that songs can only be
moved onto an iPod and not off of an
iPod the iPod needs to know that the
instructions being given to it by given
to it by a PC to which it's tethered are
emanating from the actual Apple approved
version of iTunes and not from something
that impersonates iTunes in order to get
it to do things that Gore Apple's aux
know if you want to be if you want to be
sure that the PVR I've have hooked up to
my TV won't record the watch wants video
on demand programs you need to be sure
that the tuner that's receiving it will
honor that flag and not output to any
devices that it doesn't trust
and if I want to be sure that you aren't
watching me through my webcam covertly I
need to know that the drivers are there
and that they're that they're faithfully
honoring the convention that when the
green light comes on the camera is on
and when the cameras on the green light
is on and if I want to be sure that you
can't aren't capturing my passwords as I
type them into my keyboard I need to
know that the OS isn't lying to me when
it says there aren't any software key
loggers on the system whether you want
to be free or whether you want to
enslave you need to have knowledge and
control over the system so that's the
coming war on general purpose computing
that's the talk I gave in Berlin now I
want to investigate what happens in the
event that we win the war on Germans
computing that's the prospect I call
becoming civil war over general-purpose
computers so I'll ask you now to
stipulate this thought experiment that
we went a victory on the freedom side
and we have computers now that
faithfully let owners know what's
running on them and let owners choose
what's running on them the computers we
get to control what's running on them
because there's something on it that
faithfully reports what's going on in
them so there are two arguments I can
make for why that would be a good thing
and the first one is a human rights
argument if your world is made of
computers then designing computers to
override the owners wishes and decisions
has significant human rights decisions
today we're worried that the Iranian
government might ban from import any
computer except for those that run
operating systems that are that will
allow them to spy on users but tomorrow
imagine if the government that I live
under the British government says that
from now on when the NHS gives you a
cochlear implant it doesn't allow you to
hear extremist speech or it takes any
extremist speech that you hear and
reports it back to the police or both
the second reason for doing this is the
property rights reason the doctrine of
first first sale it's a very important
piece of consumer law it says that once
you buy something you own something it
belongs to you and you have the freedom
to do anything you want even if it
pisses off the vendor now digital rights
management opponents like me like saying
things like if you bought it you own it
property rights are a very very powerful
argument
have on your side especially in America
where there's strong property rights
enforcement is often seen as the
foundation of social remedies this goes
double for this neighborhood for Silicon
Valley you can't swing a cat for hitting
someone who believes that the major or
only legitimate function of governments
is to enforce property rights and the
contracts around them which is to say
that if you want to win a nerd fight
property rights are a powerful weapon to
have on your side and not just nerd
fights if you go to DC it's a great
place to have it's a great thing to have
on your side too and this is why people
involved in in the copyright fight are
so touchy about the term intellectual
property which was brought in very
cynically in the mid 70s to replace the
term of art of the day which was the
intellectual monopoly or the creators
monopoly creators monopoly is a hard
thing to argue for going to a regulator
or law maker and saying my monopoly
isn't being forced vigorously enough is
a lot less palatable than my property
rights are being trampled upon so this
is this is where the civil rights part
comes in the Civil War part comes in I
beg your pardon
human rights and property rights both
demand that computers not be designed
for remote control from governments and
corporations and so on that is owners
should be allowed to specify the
software they're running to freely
choose the nub of certainty from which
they suspend the scaffold of their
computers security now remember security
is relative you are there's no such
thing as abstract security you can only
be secured from attack up from a certain
attack so I might be secured from my
attack on my from an attack on my
ability to freely use my music when if
you can control my computing environment
but if I can control my music and you
can't control my computing environment
and you're the record industry then you
are less secure and your ability to
charge rent every time I want to listen
to music if I get to choose the nub from
which the scaffold dangles I get control
and power to secure myself against
attackers now if the Recording Industry
Association of America or the government
or Monsanto get to choose that nub then
they get the control and the power to
secure themselves against me so let's
all agree at the very least that owners
should be able to know and control the
saw
we're running on their computers but
what about users users of computers
don't always have the same interests as
owners of computers and increasingly we
are all going to be the users of
computers we don't own because we are
going to inhabit a world made of
computers where you come down on the
conflicts between users and owners I
think will end up being one of the more
meaningful questions of the coming
century and there's no easy answer I
know of for figuring out where not where
to land given any city any situation no
rule of thumb that works for everything
so let's start with a position we can
call the property maximalist right
here's here's black stone on property if
it's my computer I should have the
absolute right to dictate to users the
terms on which they can use it if you
don't like the rules that I've set for
my computer go use someone else's
computer how does that work in practice
well we can have some combination of of
law and technology you get a computer
and out of the box it asks you to give
it a password an administrative password
and then when you've given it the
administrator and all the administrator
can choose who's operating systems they
trust so no one else is allowed to come
and tell you what to trust and you can
tell anyone who wants to use the
computer which operating systems it's
going to run so you generate a random
signature and that signature or you
write generators that you have a
signature that signatures used to
generate a random key in that that
belongs to you without that key no one
can change the list of trusted parties
now we could even make it against the
law to subvert that system for the
purposes of tricking people into running
software they didn't choose themselves
that would make spyware extra super
illegal and it would also make sneaking
DRM onto people's computers illegal we
can design this TPM so that if you
tamper with it or you remove it it
becomes really obvious you know you give
it a fragile housing so that anytime you
you attack it it kind of breaks apart
and anyone can tell that something funny
is going on
now I can see lots of benefits to this
but there unquestionably some downsides
too so think for a minute of
self-driving cars now there's a lot of
these around already of course coming
out of Google and elsewhere and it's
easy to understand on the one hand
while I self-driving cars would be
incredibly awesome because as a species
we are terrible drivers seriously I mean
cars kill the [ __ ] out of us it is the
number one cause of deaths for people in
America aged 5 to 34 now I've been hit
by a car and I've also cracked up a car
and I'm perfectly willing to stipulate
that human beings have no business
driving cars now it's also easy to
understand how we might be nervous about
people being too able to home brew their
own firmware for self-driving cars on
the one hand we'll want the source code
for cars to be widely published so that
we can all scrutinize it and make sure
it's good but on the other hand I think
there's going to be a very plausible
argument to say some authoritarian body
gets to certify what's running on the
highways now we're back to the now we
get back to this problem of whether or
not you get to decide whether a computer
you own the computer in your car you get
to decide what it's doing now there's
two problems with this solution the
first one of course is that it won't
work as the copyright wars have shown us
firmware locks aren't very effective
against determined attackers who are
sitting in front of them people who want
to sow mayhem with their custom firmware
are going to be able to and what's more
this is just not a good security
approach if the hick Euler security
models depend on all other vehicles
being well behaved and the unexpected
never arising we are all dead meat
self-driving cars need to be
conservative in the approach and their
approach to their own conduct and they
need to be liberal in their expectation
of other people's conduct it's the
advice you got on day one a driver's ed
and it's good advice whether a human
being is behind the wheel or a computer
is but the second reason is is a more
kind of philosophical and social one
because the when you start to say well
there are classes of devices that
everyday people own that some remote
authorities should be able to override
their decisions on it invites some
pretty ugly parallels you remember the
term information superhighway if we can
justify securing the physical roads by
demanding that the state or some state
like entity gets to certify the firmware
of the devices that crews on its lanes
how do we articulate a policy on
explaining why the
vices on our equally vital virtual
highways with comparable with comparable
firmware locks for PCs and phones and
tablets and other devices why those
shouldn't be under state control after
all we have a general-purpose network
and that general-purpose 'no smiie pnes
that MRIs spaceships air traffic control
systems and so on all share the
information superhighway with your
Gameboy your Arduino linked fart machine
and the dodgy voyeur canceled by
spammers from the Pearl River Delta and
and think for a moment about a V onyx
and power station automation these are
much trickier questions at the FAA
mandates a certain firmware for 747s
it's probably gonna want those 747s
designs so that it and it alone controls
the signing keys for their boot loaders
and just as the Nuclear Regulatory
Commission will want the final say on
the form we're running on reactor piles
now this may be a problem for the same
reason that modifying that a ban on
modifying car firmware will be a problem
because it establishes the idea that the
authorities should be allowed to control
the firmware on some device that that
belongs to you or some other private
entity but might and maybe that
airplanes and nukes are so different
from all the other things that we own
that that wouldn't happen I mean there
are already subject to such overweening
regulation you know no-knock warrants
and and surprise inspections that it may
be that adding another layer of
regulatory control won't lead us to
think well if you can control airplanes
why not you're the computer on your desk
but there's a there's a bigger problem
with owner controls what about people
who use computers but don't own them
this is not a group of people that the
eight IT industry has had a lot of
sympathy for on the whole we have
devoted an enormous amount of energy to
stopping non owning users from doing a
bunch of crazy things like inadvertently
breaking the computers that they're
using downloading menu bars typing
random [ __ ] they find on the internet
into their terminals plugging malware
infected USB sticks in disabling
firewalls installing plugins adding
repositories adding certificates to the
machines of the browser's trust route
punching holes on the network perimeter
by accident or accidentally cross
connecting the networks that are
required to remain separate like the
sensitive internal
work in the untrusted public network and
to stop users from deliberately doing
bad things like installing key loggers
and spyware that they used to attack
future users or misappropriating secrets
that are on the network or snooping on
network traffic or deliberately breaking
their machines or deliberately punching
holes in the network's perimeter or
deliberately disabling the firewall or
deliberately interconnecting those
networks that are supposed to remain
separate there's a kind of symmetry here
DRM and it's cousins are deployed by
companies who believe that you can't and
shouldn't be able trusted to set policy
on your own computer IT systems are
deployed by computer by computer owners
who believe that computer users can't be
trusted to set policies on the computers
that they use now I'm a former systems
administrator and a former CIO and I'm
not going to pretend that users aren't a
challenge every day for people who
managed IT systems but I think that
there are good reasons to treat users as
having rights to set policies on the
computers that they don't own I want to
start with the easy one the business
case for this when we demand freedom for
owners we do so for lots of reasons but
one important reason is that computer
programmers just can't anticipate all
the contingencies that their code might
run up against that when the computer
says yes owners still might need to say
no and when the computer says no owners
still might need to say yes the idea
that owners might possess situational
awareness that just can't be perfectly
captured in a series of nested if then
statements now this is where communism
and libertarianism converge this guy
Hayek thought that expertise was a
diffuse thing and that you were more
likely to find the situational awareness
good for good decision-making very close
to the decision itself devolution gives
you better results than centralization
and then there's this guy who thought
that the believed in the legitimacy of
workers claims over their working
environment saying that cut that the
contribution of labour was just as
important as the contribution of capital
and demanding that workers be treated as
the light rightful owners of their
workplace with the power to set policy
over it for totally opposite reasons
these two believed that the people at
the coalface should be given as much
power
as possible now the death of mainframes
was attended by an awful lot of concerns
over users and what they might do to
their enterprises in those days users
were even more constrained by their IT
system than they are today they could
only see the screens that the mainframe
let them see and only undertake the
mainframes that the mainframe let them
undertake the operations that the
mainframe let them undertake when the PC
and VisiCalc and Lotus 1-2-3 appeared
employees actually risked getting fired
by bringing those machines into the
office or bringing home office data to
run on them at home because they had a
computing need that couldn't be met by
the constraints set by their firms and
by the its IT department and because
they didn't think that if they came to
their IT department or their employers
with their demands that they would be
recognized as legitimate after all the
standard response to something like that
from a user is one or more of the
following are regulatory compliance
prohibits you're doing the thing that
will help you do your job better if you
do your job that way we won't know if
you've done it right you only think you
want to do your job that way it's
impossible to make a computer do what
you want it to do corporate policy
prohibits doing your job that way now
some or all of these may be true
although they often aren't and even when
they are true they're the kind of truths
that we give bright young geeks millions
of dollars in venture capital to falsify
while middle-aged administrative
assistants merely get written up by HR
for trying to do the same thing the prom
the personal computer arrived into the
enterprise by the backdoor over the
objections of the IT department without
the knowledge of management at the risk
of censure and termination and it made
the companies that fought at billions
trillions the reason that giving workers
more powerful more flexible tools was
good for firms is that people are
generally smart and they generally want
to do their jobs and because they know
stuff that their bosses don't know as an
owner you don't want the devices that
you buy locked because you might want to
do something that the designer didn't
anticipate and employees don't want the
devices that
use all day locked because they might
want to do something that the IT
department didn't anticipate this is the
soul of Hayek ISM we're smarter at the
edge than we are in the middle but it's
something that the business world only
pays lip service to and the these ideas
that came into the 1940s from Hayek and
free markets but when it comes to
freedom within the companies that they
run most businesses operate in a
paradigm that's a good 50 years older
mired in the ideology of this guy
Frederick Winslow Taylor and his idea of
scientific management the idea that
workers are just a particularly
unreliable kind of machine whose
movements and actions should be scripted
and constrained by an all-knowing
management consultant who would work
with an equally wise company series of
company bosses to determine the one true
way that you should do your job in other
words the ideology that led Toyota Kreme
Detroit's Big Three automakers during
the car wars in the 1980s
so letting enterprise users do stuff
that they think will allow them to get
there to make more money for their
companies will sometimes make their
companies more money also the scientific
management is about as scientific as
trepanation and myers-briggs tests the
business case for user rights is a good
one but I really just wanted to get it
out of the way so that I could get down
to the real meat here the human rights
case now it may seem a little weird on
its face to talk about human rights here
but bear with me early this year I saw a
talk by this guy Hugh hare the director
of the biomech at mekin atronics group
at the MIT Media Lab basically the
prostheses lab now some of you probably
seen hairdo talks there's some amazing
ones on YouTube it's electrifying now he
starts out with a bunch of slides of all
these cool prostheses that they've built
in their labs there's you know legs and
feet and hands and arms and then there's
even this device that uses focused
magnetism to suppress activity in the
brains of people with severe untreatable
depression - amazing effect and then he
shows this slide of him climbing a
mountain and he's buffed he's clinging
to the rock like a gecko and oh yeah he
doesn't have any legs
he just has these cool mountain climbing
prostheses and he looks at the audience
for
where he's been standing and kind of
pacing back and forth on the stage and
he says oh yeah didn't I mention I don't
have any legs and he rolls up his pants
legs to show off these amazing robotic
gams and he proceeds to run up and down
the stage leaping around like a mountain
goat now the first question when I saw
him that anyone asked was how much do
those legs cost and he named a sum that
would buy you a brownstone in central
Manhattan or a terrorist Victorian in
zone one London and the second question
that someone asked me was who's gonna be
able to afford these things and he said
well everyone if you're choosing between
a 40-year mortgage on a house and having
legs you're gonna choose legs which is
all by way of asking you to consider the
possibility that there going to be
people potentially a lot of people who
are going to be users of computers that
they don't own where those computers are
going to be parts of their bodies now I
think that most of the tech world can
understand why as you as the owner of
your cochlear implants should be legally
allowed to choose the firmware that runs
on them after all when you own a device
that is surgically implanted in your
skull it makes a lot of sense that you
should have the freedom to change
software vendors maybe the company that
major implant has the very best signal
processing algorithm right now but what
if a competitor patents a superior
algorithm next year should you be doomed
to having inferior hearing for the rest
of your life or the life of the patent
this is a problem that can't be overcome
merely by escrowing the code the sort of
thing that you might do if you wanted to
be protected against the company going
bankrupt or by publishing the code the
sort of thing you might do if you wanted
to be sure there were no shenanigans
going on this is a problem that can only
be overcome by the unambiguous right to
change the software even if the company
that major implants is a going concern
and doesn't want you to so that helps
owners but what about users now consider
some of the following scenarios say
you're a minor child and you're deeply
religious parents pay for your cochlear
implants and they ask for the software
that makes it impossible for you to hear
blasphemy or you're broke and a
commercial company wants to sell you ad
supported implants that listen in on
your conversations and insert content
jewelle adds that trigger discussions
about the brands you love or your
government is willing to install
cochlear implants but they'll archive
everything you hear and review it
without your knowledge or consent that
may sound far-fetched but consider that
just a few months ago the Canadian
government was forced to abandon plans
to put hidden microphones throughout the
nation's airports so they could listen
in on every conversation going on and
find the bad ones will the Iranian
government or the Chinese government
take advantage of this if they get the
chance
and speaking of Iran and China it's
these there are plenty of human rights
activists who believe that boot locking
is the start of a human rights disaster
in countries like them it's no secret
that there are plenty of high tech
companies that have been happy to build
these lawful interception backdoors into
their equipment to allow for warrantless
secret access to communications these
factors are now standard so even if your
country doesn't want the capability it's
still there now in Greece there wasn't
any legal requirement for lawful
intercept on their telecoms equipment
but during the 2004 and 5 Olympics
bidding process an unknown person or
agency switched on the dormant
capability and harvest an unknown
quantity of private communications from
the highest levels and then switched it
off again no one knows who no one knows
what they got no one knows what they did
with it or if they do they're not saying
surveillance in the middle of the
network is nowhere near as interesting
as surveillance at the edge if you can
control the devices instead of the
network you can find out all kinds of
juicy things as the ghosts of misters
Hayek and Marx will tell you there's a
lot of stuff going on at the coalface
that never makes it back to the central
office and even so-called democratic
governments know this that's why the
Bavarian government was illegally
installing this Boone destroy honor a
state Trojan on people's computers
gaining access to their files and
keystrokes and much else besides it is a
safe bet that the totalitarian
governments of the world will happily
take advantage of boot locking and move
the surveillance right into the box you
may not import a computer into Iran
unless you limit its trust model so that
it only boots up operating systems with
the lawful intercept or backdoors built
right into the
now assume we get an owner controls
model we're in the first person to use a
machine gets to initialize the list of
trusted keys and then lock it with a
secret or another authorization token
all this means is that the state customs
authority has to initialize every
machine as it enters the country before
it passes into users hands now maybe
you'll be able to do something to
override that trust model but by design
the system will be heavily
tamper-evident meaning that a secret
policeman or a garden-variety snitch
will be able to tell at a glance whether
you've modified your computer to lock
the state out of it and it's not just
repressive states of course remember
that there are four major customers for
sense aware spyware and lock where
there's repressive governments large
corporations schools and helicopter
parents that is to say that the needs of
paranoid parents school systems and
enterprises converge with those of the
governments of Syria and China they
don't share ideological ends but they
have awfully similar technological means
to attain their individual ends and
we're very forgiving of institutions as
they pursue those ends you can do almost
anything if you're doing it to protect
shareholders or children for example you
may remember that there was widespread
indignation from all sides when it was
revealed that some companies were
requiring worse prospective employees to
hand over their facebook login
credentials as a condition of employment
now these employers argued that they
needed to review the lists of friends
and what you said when you were in your
private moments before determining
whether you were suitable for working
their Facebook logins were fast becoming
the workplace urine testing of the 21st
century a means of ensuring that your
private life didn't have any unsavory
secrets lurking in it secrets that might
compromise your working life now the
nation wasn't buying this from Senate
hearings two popular editorials the
country rose up against this practice
but no one seems to mind that employers
routinely insert their own intermediate
keys and to their employees devices
their phones their tablets and their
computers these allowed them to spy on
their internet traffic even when it's
secured with a little log showing in the
browser
it gives the employers access to any
sensitive site you visit on the job from
your unions message board to your bank
to Gmail to your HMO or your doctor's
private patient messaging area to
Facebook there's a wide consensus that
this is okay because the laptop phone or
tablet that your employer issues to you
is not your property their company
property and yet the reason that
employers give us these mobile devices
is because there's no longer any
meaningful distinction between work and
home
corporate sociologists who study the way
that we use our devices time and again
find that employees are not capable of
maintaining strict divisions between
their work and personal accounts and
devices america is the land of the fifty
five hour work week a country where very
few professionals take any meaningful
vacation and when they do they go abroad
with their BlackBerry's even in
traditional old pre-digital workplaces
we recognize the human rights of workers
on company property we didn't put
cameras in the toilets took her tail
employee theft by and large if your
spouse came by the office while you were
on your lunch break and the two of you
went into the parking lot so that she or
he could tell you that the doctor says
that the cancer is terminal
you'd be aghast and furious to know that
that conversation had been recorded by
hidden camera and microphone but if you
use your company laptop to access
Facebook on your lunch break
wherein your spouse conveys to you the
fact that the cancer is terminal you're
supposed to be okay with your employer
knowing that because they've been
running a man-in-the-middle attack on
your personal life and on the most
intimate into intimate details thereof
there are plenty of instances in which
rich and powerful people and not just
corporate peons or children or prisoners
will be users instead of owners of the
devices around them every car rental
agency would be love would love to be
able to not just LoJack the cars they
rent you remember cars or computers you
put your body into they'd love to log
all the places you've been for marketing
purposes and analytics there's lots of
money to be made in finagling the
firmware on your rental car GPS to
ensure that your routes always take you
past certain billboards
but in general the poorer and younger
you are the more likely you are to be a
tenant farmer and some feudal lords
computational lands the more likely that
your legs will cease to walk if you get
behind on payments meaning that any thug
who buys your debts from a payday lender
can literally and legally threaten to
take your legs or eyes or ears or arms
or insulin or pacemaker away if you
don't come up with the next payment now
before I discussed how an owner override
would work some combination of physical
physical access control tamper evidence
designed to give users of computers
owners of computers rather the power to
know and control what bootloader and
operating system are running on them now
how would he use your override work I
think effective user override would have
to leave the underlying computer intact
as a first design principle now here's a
totally hypothetical model for this this
is the bit that I'm telling that I
mentioned before it's not a
technological proposal it's an example
imagine that there's a bootloader that
can reliably and accurately report on
the kernels and operating systems it
finds on the drive this is the
prerequisite for any of these scenarios
the one in which the state of the
corporation gets to control how owners
use of the devices the one in which
owners get to use their devices and the
one in which I'm about to describe and
which users get to control their devices
now give this hypothetical bootloader
the power to suspend any running
operating system to disk encrypting all
of its threads and files so that the
person sitting at the console can no
longer access them so you walk into an
internet cafe or some other context in
which you're using a device that you
don't own and you park the operating
system and you now have the power to
select the OS from another from a thumb
drive or from the network and now
imagine that the internet cafe has a
some kind of lawful interception
backdoor for the police now you you're
an attorney you're a doctor you're a
corporate executive or just a human
being who doesn't like the idea of your
private stuff being available to anyone
who's friends with a dirty cop so you do
this three finger salute with your F
keys to drop into this minimal
bootloader shell one that invites you to
give the net address
some alternative OS or insert your thumb
drive the cafe owners operating system
is parked you can't see it anymore but
the bootloader can assure you that it's
dormant and not spying on you as your OS
fires up and when your OS has done all
of its working files are trashed and the
bootloader confirms it
not just because this keeps the
computers owner from spying on you but
because it stops you from attacking the
users owner or other users that come by
there will be a technological means of
server ting this but there's a world of
difference between starting from the
design spec that aims to protect users
from owners and vice versa
than one that says that users must
always be vulnerable to the owner's
wishes fundamentally this amounts to the
difference between freedom and openness
between what we've called free software
and open source for all these years for
a long time these have seemed like
distinctions without a difference I
think that we are slowly acquiring the
meaningful difference between them now
human rights and property rights often
come into conflict with conflict with
one another for example landlords aren't
allowed to enter your house without
adequate notice even if you rent it from
them in many places your hotel can't
throw you out if you're paying the rate
even if you overstay your reservation
the repo man can't come and take your
car away without going through some
procedure and giving you the opportunity
to rebut an accusation of being
delinquent in your payments and when
these when these processes are
streamlined to make them easier for the
property owners we often see human
rights abuses like when Robo signers
working for eviction mills use
fraudulent declarations to evict
homeowners who are caught up on their
mortgages or even people who don't have
mortgages the potential for abuse in a
world made of computers is much greater
imagine your car driving itself into the
repo yard or your high-rise apartment
building switching off its elevators in
climate systems stranding thousands of
people until a distributed lot until a
disputed license payment is made now
this already actually happened once
before back in 2006 there was a 314 car
robotic parking model RPS 1000 garage in
Hoboken New Jersey that took all the
cars and its guts hostage it locked down
the software until the owners of the
garage paid a licensing bill that they
disputed
they paid it even though they maintained
that they didn't owe it because what the
hell else were they gonna do there were
300 cars trapped in the belly of this
machine what will you do when your
dispute with a vendor means that you go
blind or deaf or lose the ability to
walk or become suicidally depressed the
negotiating leverage that accrues to
owners / users is total and terrifying
users will be strongly incentivized to
settle quickly rather than face the
dreadful penalties that could be visited
on them in the event of a dispute and
when the owner of the device is the
state or a state size corporate actor
the potential for human abuse rights
skyrockets this is not to say that owner
override is an unmitigated evil think
for a minute of these smart meters they
can override your thermostat at peak
levels without the ability to tell your
house to change its HVAC at the right
moment we won't be able to switch off
coal and other dirty power sources that
are the sorts of things that we can vary
and ramp up at peak demand but these
things work best if the users the
homeowners who allow the party company
the power company to install them in
their homes can't override them but what
happens when griefers or crooks or a
government trying to quell a popular
rebellion use this to turn off the heat
during 100-year storm or crank the heat
up to maximum during a heatwave the HVAC
in your house can hold the power of life
and death over you do we really want it
designed to allow remote parties to set
policy on it that you can't override the
question is wants me to create a design
norm of devices that users can't
override how far will that creep
especially risky would be the use of
owner override to offer payday loan
style services to vulnerable people if
you can't afford artificial eyes for
your kids will subsidize them only if
you let us redirect their focus to
sponsor toys and sugar snacks at the
store but foreclosing on all an owner
over I probably means that there's going
to be poor people who will not be
offered some technology at all if I can
LoJack your legs I can lease them to you
with the confidence of my power to repo
them if you default on payments if I
can't I may not lease you legs at all
unless you're already rich but if you
but if your legs can decide to walk to
the repo Depot without your consent you
will be totally screwed the day that's
some mugger or
Pistor griefer or the secret police
figure out how to hijack that facility
it gets even more complicated of course
because you are the user of many systems
in the most transitory way subway
turnstiles elevators the blood pressure
cuff at your doctor's office a public
bus or an airplane it's going to be hard
to figure out how to create a user
override that isn't nonsensical although
we might start by saying users are
someone who are the sole user of a
device for a certain amount of time as I
said at the start of this talk this is
not a problem I know how to solve
unlike the coming war on general purpose
computing the civil war over them seems
to present a series of conundrum without
a single clean line of solutions which
is why I'm talking to this audience
about them these problems are way off
but we're supposed to be thinking in the
long term here and of course they'll
only arise if we win the war on
computers first but come victory day
when we start planning the
constitutional Congress for the new
world we're regulating computers is
acknowledged as the wrong way to solve
problems
let's not paper over the division
between human rights and property rights
this is the sort of division that while
it festers puts the most vulnerable
people in our society in harm's way
agreeing to disagree on this one is not
good enough we need to start thinking
now about the principles that will apply
when the day comes because if we don't
start now it may be too late thank you
a certain an analogue question mm-hmm
you've been in Britain how long often on
since 2003 they've been doing more
surveillance cameras than almost anybody
yeah there must be some serious
parallels between what's been going on
what's playing out there versus some of
these human property privacy issues
you're raising in terms of computers
what have you got so far from that what
have they got from that well you know I
think one of the big problems with the
UK is the conflation of solving crimes
and preventing crimes it seems like
there's a lot of times where cameras
solve crimes but they often seem to
serve as a as a substitute for for the
kind of boots on the street that might
prevent crime so for example I know
someone who was a murdered near his
house he came up out of a tube station
there used to be a human guard there and
that human guard had been replaced by a
camera and that camera did capture the
three kids who followed him out of the
tube and stabbed him to death and took
his phone and they were later captured
on the basis of it but he's still dead
right I think that that cameras aren't
the same thing as people and moreover I
think that cameras kind of change our
behavior in in lots of ways that we're
still making sense of and they lead us
to weird and nonsensical conclusions I
mean Britain has this love-hate
relationship with cameras they will
arrest you for taking out your camera
but they will take your picture over and
over again I the weirdest of these is
the daycare that we take my daughter to
every day we walk 10 minutes to to the
to the daycare and you know Britain has
like 14 CCTVs per red blood cell now
which means that we're photographed like
a million times on the way to the
daycare and when you get to the daycare
there's a CCTV over the door and beneath
it is a sign that says in the interest
of safety please don't turn on your
camera in the daycare which is to say we
can take lots of pictures of you but you
can't take any pictures of us I was IRA
prized my role this year as the atheist
Jewish Santa Claus of the East End day
care and we weren't allowed to take any
pictures of any of the of me because
there might be a kid in it and once you
take a picture of a kid I don't know
what you'll do with it but somehow it's
linked to pedophilia god I've never
understood it myself
which somehow erases all argument for
some so it's been going on that long in
Britain or this is the populist sort of
moving in some direction relation to all
that as the government moving in some
relation to all of that or is it they
put up all the cameras and that's I
think the fraud has been boiled I mean
nobody can really articulate what it's
supposed to do and and it is one of
these things there's a whole class of
you know old lady who swallowed a fly
problems we're having swallowed the fly
you need to swallow a spider and a bird
and so on where you know if the CCTVs
aren't solving the problem the problem
must be that there aren't enough CCTVs
and you can like like any problem can be
solved by just adding more CCTVs and
they oftentimes you know one of the
problems with these things is that they
well they're a suite of them one is that
weirdos and bad guys might be looking
out of them right so that puts you at
risk one is that face that when you have
a lot of them it's very hard to keep
them all working so the important you've
got this sort of maintenance rota that
doesn't distinguish between CCTVs that
are in places where you know the
research shows you that you can prevent
crime like parking garages which is
places where people are often on their
own and where it's you know quite easy
to pull off a crime and get away clean
and the CCTV that's just sort of
reflexively puts somewhere because CCTVs
add magic security dust to any public
location and and as a result you you end
up with a kind of because there's no
theory behind it there's no one's out an
articulate able theory about safety that
relates to CCTVs except CCTVs make us
safer
there's no way to deploy the system
rationally it's just it's just
doctrinaire question from poll clip oh
it's interesting he's got two questions
only the first one is here given the
move to cloud computing don't we all
become users that's certainly true
although you know you could imagine like
some combination of cryptography and
virtual machines making you the owner of
our owner and some meaningful sense of a
computer that you're not physically
present at but yeah I mean there's
certainly lots and lots of computers
that we use every day that we don't own
and one of the things I'm getting from
all right there's a really good question
here mmm
basically the question relates to this
has been going on for a while what
you're talking about
and what you're saying is it's going to
keep going on for a while so the 50
years plus or minus of dealing with
computers that we're in that are in us
that we live in that have given us a set
of trends that you're responding to and
that as a science fiction writer you're
then thinking where those trends go and
what makes them flip into something else
and so on what is your overall sense of
the last 50 years leading to the next
period of time well so I think for the
last maybe for the last 20 years anyways
that kind of the period of the drm Wars
okay there's been the sense that
property owners rights are being taken
away there's this fight between like a
kind of notional property and real
property that that because everything
that you own contains something licensed
that you are you're that kind of clean
ownership that's in some ways illusory
anyways but that clean kind of blackwell
Ian's ownership Blackstone Ian's
ownership where you have the you know
absolute Tyranny over your device is
being eroded that that you know that
your your real property rights in your
TV or your phone or your computer are
being taken away because they're being
governed by EULA's that kind of you you
you agree to just by sort of by standing
here and shouting no no no I don't agree
you agree that I'm allowed to come over
to your house and clean out your fridge
and wear your underwear and make some
long-distance calls you know so I think
that that that has been a building
consensus right that there's a lot of
people who really agree with that and
and I I agree with it that and that this
is improper that that it's that whatever
it is that we use to kind of regulate
information it shouldn't be at the
expense of the right to you know take a
picture of your shoes even though they
embody a design path
owned by someone or take a picture of
your t-shirt even though it has some
copyrighted mark on it or you know
record your kid dancing in your kitchen
and put put the adorable toddler on
YouTube even though there are some faint
strains of prints playing in the
background right these these things come
up and they are they're important issues
and I think that by and large we go ya
know that's right we should you own it
you bought it you own it it's yours
whatever it is we do to regulate
information let's not do it at the
expense of of owning stuff but there's
also this increased consensus I think
that like your company's IT department
has the right to tell you what you do
with your computers and if you don't
like it you should work at a different
company and I think that that's that's
our reflexive answer that's not a very
good answer you know I wrote a column
about the fact that we weren't pissed
off when when Facebook logins were
captured by employers when users used
their company computers to access
Facebook even on their lunch breaks or
whatever but we were pissed off when
when prospective employees were required
to give their credentials the idea was
like and the email that I got from this
universally said you're an idiot right
IT departments have the responsibility
and duty first of all to spy and
everything their users do because how
else would you stop company secrets from
leaking out or house would you have
HIPAA compliance or how else would you
have some other compliance regime in the
enterprise and then they also said
you're an idiot because it's your it's
your boss's computer why are you doing
something personal on it it's it's you
know if you want to do something
personal use your own computer but you
know we're not we're not really good at
maintaining clean divisions between user
computers and owner computers and and
moreover as I said in the talk you know
there's lots of times where you're on
your employer's property where your
employer's dominion over your inter
relationships with other people and
you're kind of your person is not
opposite absolute so why should it be
absolute just because there's a computer
in the middle of it
why is it that Facebook credentials are
beyond the pale for prospective
employees but
you know justjust just a thing that you
had you should sort of suck it up and if
you don't like it use someone else's
computer once you take the job I guess
since you're saying that this that
you're talking about property rights and
human rights and the property rights
seems to be an endless condition of
negotiation and battle and a civil war
and so on whereas the human rights I get
the sense you're saying is a little more
absolute and it doesn't change so much
over time yeah yeah yeah I mean well
well Human Rights always then be able to
sort of clarify the issues no I actually
I don't think human rights are
unchangeable over time because I think
that there are human rights questions
that we've never had to answer like
control over your sensorium or universal
surveillance or even negotiating the
difference between you know like we've
always had you know a certain abhorrence
for people who go and read your private
diary in order to incriminate you I'd
have me once but but horrible but but I
mean what about your life logger what
about your Fitbit what about you know
there's a kind of depth of information
captured there that on the one hand
seems kind of like impersonal right and
yes there you go you know like like your
pulse at any given time you know why why
should that be private but at the same
time could be quite damning taken as a
whole I kind of feel like these
disclosures they're a bit like
involuntary disclosures or even
voluntary ones sometimes are a bit like
smoking right taking a puff of a
cigarette won't give you cancer but if
enough people take enough puffs of
cigarettes some of them will get cancer
and being disclosing once won't put you
in harm's way probably but enough
disclosures over wide enough population
is going to create some really weird
pathological outcomes and when those
disclosures are compelled because they
come out of the devices that is even
more potentially harmful so as part of
this driven by just the pace of change
because norms emerge laws emerge
regulations that people feel okay about
emerge
but if you got Moore's Law chugging
along behind all of this and just making
it a whole new engineering and you swirl
every few years does that mean that
norms never get to catch up and there's
always gonna be Civil War for the
foreseeable future well I mean I don't
think that it's that it's merely future
shock or you know acceleration shock I
think that like you know people I
sometimes hear people say privacy is
dead but it seems to me that privacy is
dead is not a description of the world
as it is but rather a slogan right I
need more money privacy is dead okay
no it's it's it's it seems like whenever
I hear someone declaring privacy dead
that person has an interest in privacy
being dead and and you know they they're
they're it's it's not a neutral it's not
a neutral observation and so you know
Larry Lessig talks about these four
regulatory forces code law technology
and norms and I think that when new
technology comes along there are lots of
norms differing norms that emerge but
the ones that emerge victorius are often
those that are prompted by people or
supported by people or support the
interests of people who already have
lots of power so you know for example I
can't figure out how to rent you music
and then rent it to you again later
unless I can control your computer
therefore controlling your computer is
bad when you know the another answer to
that might be why is renting your
computer and absolutely why is renting
music to me an absolute right I mean if
you can't figure out how to rent
computer music to me without doing
something so obviously wrong then you
should get another another line of work
right it seems to me that like there's
nothing a priori like if you are a
Martian watching the earth through a
telescope
there'd be nothing about one or the
other that would tell you that that
seems like on its face to be a more
reasonable claim right you know renting
music not renting music there's there's
no there's no absolute kind of necessity
that music be rentable question for him
John Foster another question he says
thank you for validating my vintage
computer fetish old hardware makes it
all future-proof yeah well no I mean
only if you don't have a modern car or
only if you don't get fitted with a
pacemaker only if you don't walk past
CCTV use only if I mean there are lots
of computers that you will end up using
that aren't visibly computers right
nothing is future-proof yeah well I
don't I mean I think being a hermit
maybe but but you know that I you know
there's that is a very you know you
versatile quote just because you're not
interested in technology doesn't mean
technology isn't interested in you you
know a little little warmed-over trotsky
their red diaper right yeah a little
fanboy question you're about to finish a
book with Charles Stross no no no no
it's been long garnished just long
finish yeah yeah no it's say something
out in September so soulless as well you
may have read the first two-thirds of it
we with the first story we ever wrote
together it's called jury service and
it's a comic novel set in a world in
which all of the technophiles have
ascended to the singularity they're all
there at they've all abandoned their
bodies and and left behind all of the
Luddites the all of the people who are
deeply religious and reject technology
and so on so the it's a it's the inverse
of the Left Behind novels in which all
of the pious people go to heaven and
this one all about all of the refuseniks
are left behind and all of they all
other kind of highly secular
technophiles go to the cloud and it's
it's and the cloud sends spam to the
earth it has
it has ideas in fact it's this it's
disassemble the whole solar system
except for the earth because it has a
sentimental attachment to it and it's
fun this giant Dyson Sphere and there's
this just this one lighthouse beam
tracking the earth as the earth goes
around the Sun and the rest of the sun's
radiant energy is being absorbed by the
bones of all the planets that are now
you know grinding computronium running
simulations of nerds and and the Nerds
send send spam to the earth with like
cool ideas they've had for what me
people can do and and there's there's a
jury that meets periodically to figure
out which of these technologies are
useable so that the protagonist of the
story is a bit like rincewind and the
terry pratchet almost kind of comic hero
is summoned to libya to attend a
people's technology court to determine
whether or not this technology is
useable so we wrote that then we wrote a
sequel called appeals court so two
novellas so toda books really liked it
and said write a third we'd always
talked about writing a third so we wrote
a third which is called parole board and
then we rewrote all three to make them
all fit together as a single unitary
story and that's that's called rapture
of the Nerds and that's coming out in
September and we'll be touring with it
if just just a little baby tour
Charlie's gonna be over for the world
science fiction convention in Chicago
and I'm gonna be at Burning Man and
we're gonna rendezvous I think we start
in New York and we're going to like New
York Lexington and Boston and then
Rochester there's the thing at RIT and
then we're going home so yeah that's
that's the that's the next book okay so
one of things you're great at and keeps
me reading your books as you you make
this wonder seeming thing come to happen
the gold farmers get together and they
organize whatever it may be and here
you've got the rapture the Nerds in
their Dyson Sphere making all this cool
stuff happens so they've attained their
rapture but the world doesn't stop what
happens then
well I mean it's a it's a series of
comic stories that are in part about the
arrogance of technological determinism
of telling people well this is this is
just gonna happen get used to it here's
the technology change things so in some
in some sense a kind of self critique
because we're as guilty of that as
anyone else
and it's also you know in the third and
the third act it's really a book about
how the fact that we can all ascend and
and do things in computers that are
impossible in the real world without the
constraints of the real world doesn't
mean that they'll be very nice and in
particular doesn't mean that they'll
that they'll be very aesthetically
pleasing so the the third act is really
about life without constraint inside a
simulated universe in which everything
kind of looks like Geocities page and
and there's a certain that that is that
is not necessarily a prediction as much
as an observation of the world that we
inhabit today you know and and that's
it's it's so we open that third act with
someone pounding at the door and the
person who lives at the house says who
is it and the voice says it's the
singularity and the person says we don't
want any and the voice at the door
pounds some more and says everything is
different now I don't want any and and
so it's a it's a bit of this kind of
idea that there that there may be
legitimate reasons not to want any so
you favor a certain variety going
forward it sounds like well I think that
you know so I had I was hanging out with
Dan Gilmore the other day that no
journalist and he he talked about this
thing he used to do where he maintained
a list of 10 things that he believed
were true and the first one is like
Microsoft is a dirty monopolist that
needs super adult supervision and every
six months he would call up people who
totally disagreed with him about the ten
things that he thought were true and get
them to tell them their best arguments
to figure out whether or not he still
thought that they were true as a means
of kind of sharpening his belief and
understanding whether or not he was
taking things for granted as he said you
know if you believe something to be
absolutely true in an era of rapid
technological change and you never
revisit that belief the one thing you
can be sure of is that you'll be wrong
eventually and so I kind of feel like we
need to investigate the possibility that
we're not right and that's one of the
things that happens in this book plus it
was really fun
it was really really fun to do this I I
did a joint talk I don't know if it was
ever put online with a guy named Peter
Biddle who's a really good guy now works
for Intel but he designed palladium he
designed trusted computing for Microsoft
and he's totally on the other side of a
lot of these issues for me then from me
and we gave we gave a talk where we
reverse positions where he gave the
position against it and I gave the
position for it and that was really good
fun trying to come up with the best
arguments the arguments that I that I
always hope no one would ever bust out
when I was arguing about it because I
couldn't think of the good one so um
arguing with yourself what have you
changed your mind about lately well I
mean TPMS I've been really thinking a
lot lately you know as I as I
contemplate sensor density in the
devices that I own I get I'm getting
increasingly worried that I need a means
of verifying what's running on them I
you know and and lots of things are
making me paranoid about that things
like the bone destroy honor the the fact
that it seems like there's a migration
path from what we call like advanced
persistent threats there are the kinds
of things that governments do into
automated attacks where it's not it's
nothing personal it's just a thing that
you can kind of execute against a
population of 10 million people until
you find the person who's vulnerable I
just saw a talk at Def Con kids actually
by Moxie Marlinspike and a couple of
friends over vulnerabilities in the near
field communication sensors and Android
phones and he took a piece of what
looked like paper and he brushed it
against a phone and thereafter the phone
belonged to him and he said well there's
some limitations you need to get the
paper very close to the phone the phone
needs to be switched on when it's
running but I'm like what if this was
what if this was confetti on as they
dropped the ball on New Year's Eve and
everyone had their camera phone out
without working he was like yeah that'd
probably work cuz thereafter you own the
phone over Bluetooth or over the public
Internet you don't have to be four
inches away to control the phone you
just need to be four inches away to put
the phone in a state where you can
control it and I kind of feel like
knowing what's going on in my computer
is becoming increasingly important i
increasing ly find myself putting
post-it notes over my webcam you know
being a little worried and I didn't used
to worry much about that
there's paranoia and so there's paranoia
as a sport right
lots of people enjoy I'm gonna be
totally secret and it's it's hard and
it's interesting and so on
it is yeah it's a fun game right it's a
little it's a great mind game to play is
it worth it
well so I think that it's so the
paranoia here is not the fear that
someone is out to get me
I don't flatter myself that anyone's
particularly out to get me the fear is
that some vast automated attack against
a range of ten million IP addresses
might catch me in it and that that might
compromise me either in small ways or in
large ways and that that compromise
could come now or further down the line
and the same way shrugging we boutta
know what's the problem well so you
remember we all thought that Usenet was
a book written on water and we wrote
things on that that we didn't intend to
ever have repeated does anybody died
because of something they wrote on
Usenet back when no no absolutely not
but but for example I think people in in
the Middle East have died because of
things that were from their computer
that's free yeah no I think that's
that's absolutely true
and and the thing about Usenet was there
came a day when it turned out that there
was an archive of Usenet Dejan News
switched on and then Google bought that
archive and Google seems to have Aden oh
shut that archive down I can't seem to
find it anymore but for a while you
could find kind of you know high-flying
calm CEOs five years earlier talking
about being in the K hole at Woodstock
and you know this was not the kind of
thing you wanted on you know the eve of
your IPO and it was it was it was a
sermon that he died come on nobody died
but it was a big man right and I think
that like we are starting to see for
example the the first glimmering of what
happens when facial recognition is
applied to the corpus of all photos ever
put on the internet and we're not far
away
from every photo on the Internet being
labeled automatically or some fraction
of every foot on the internet being
labeled automatically and and and then
there being you know social graph
analysis against that of people that you
never wanted to disclose you knew and
that might lead to people dying or
losing their jobs or later being
compromised in some way
small or large and I think that there's
that so I don't worry particularly that
someone will attack me I worry that if
something gets extracted from my
computer that later on it might be
correlated with lots of other things and
that I might come to regret it later I
think we're really bad at judging the
net present value of a future option on
a disclosure right we don't know what
it's going to be worth in 20 years is
why Facebook is such a problem because
if the basis of Facebook is people can
can rationally measure the value of a of
a disclosure today again against the
value they get from Facebook and and the
total value of that disclosure over the
life of that disclosure living on
Facebook the empirical evidence is that
they're really bad at that at that
valuation it's like some of what we're
talking about here is the difference
between anticipatory problem solving and
retroactive problem solving and this is
Jimmy Wales parable the steak knives
yeah sure you know where is programmers
wanted to say well our users might do
this bad thing here will write this
really nifty software prevent them from
doing that and Jimmy said wait a goddamn
minute see if there's actually a problem
and then solve that much easier to solve
a problem you can see then a problem
that you can imagine because the
problems you can imagine are infinite
well we already have lots of weird
problems where people take over
computers then that that they people who
own them or use them I mean Lower Merion
School District was the canary in the
coal mine here affluent suburb of Philly
they issue every student a MacBook the
students are required to use the MacBook
to do their homework they're required to
bring it to school every day and home
every night and what the what the school
district did was they installed covert
software that allowed them to operate
the webcam without turning on the little
green light and in theory this was to
stop thieves but in practice it turned
out it did they were just watching the
kids lots of times and the way that they
discovered this is there was a kid who'd
had a long run
dispute with this principal he was a
discipline case principal called him in
and says I got you now sunny you've been
taking drugs hands him a photo of the
kid that were taking pills in his room
and the kid says first of all that's a
Mike and Ikes candy and second of all
how'd you get a picture of me in my
bedroom and it turns out that they'd
taken thousands of pictures of this kid
at home and at school naked and dress
with his parents on his own and you know
that's that's an inkling of what can
come because it's durable that what
happened was it corrected or on to this
day what they were sued right they were
sued they lost and they got into trouble
that in other schools that version well
no in fact I was just at DEFCON kids and
I gave and talked and I and and I gave a
talk about school networks and school
computers and the control they exert
over their kids and the kids put his
hand up and he said oh my computer does
way more than this kind of network
censors censorship and surveillance
stuff my computer every 15 minutes puts
up a dialogue reminding me that they can
watch me and see me and see everything I
do and and and so they're just not
keeping it a secret anymore right no
software but are you being fearful
enough by entering by entering this
space you agree that you will be
recorded right you've seen those signs
in fact I just landed at some airports
somewhere that said and like on the in
the customs cue we are video recording
today if you object to being recorded
please don't enter this area the customs
cue right
you are being video recorded through
your school computer if you object to
being recorded drop out of school I
don't know be a be a truant well there's
a guy here in town will give you money
to drop out of school after my own heart
Peter Teal'c is serious money the people
draw from Burning Man so you went to
Burning Man last year I gather and
you're gonna skip the science fiction
convention this year to go to Burning
Man again what's that about yeah I'm
skipping the world science fiction
convention is here for the first time
the second world kind of mist in about
18 years 19 years now Hiro's going to
Burning Man yeah mm-hmm though here it's
going to be in my camp at Burning Man I
think some of my camp mates are here hi
guys what's your camp it's where I'm
camping with the liminal labs who are
these awesome folks I know from when I
lived in San Francisco and when in the
heyday of the well and they have this
amazingly organized camp that we camped
in last year for the first time it was
my first time at Burning Man and I'd
always assumed that Burning Man would be
two things it would be very austere
because who the hell can be bothered to
bring stuff out to the desert and and it
turns out that that's totally wrong but
it's incredibly lavish that everyone
takes it as a challenge let's see what
kind of crazy stunt I can pull off in
the desert and I also thought it'd be
very doctrinaire I thought that it would
all it would always be about the that
you know these ten principles and then
everywhere you went there'd be people
quoting the ten principles like mouths
little red book at you and in fact
although the ten principles are clearly
central to what you do at Burning Man
and anytime anyone quotes them they do
so with an ironic I roll knowing how
weird and ridiculous it is to be quoting
these ten principles can you state some
of the gen principles and doctrine EU
enough to gosh oh and I remember there's
no dogs I participate don't SPECT it I
probably can't get no spectators Leave
No Trace or some other you Leave No
Trace what else gift economy what
immediacy imagine see so radical
self-reliance remember the ten rules
[ __ ] and so it was it was so
transformative and amazing that I'm
going back this year and skipping the
world con and then for the next like
five years it looks like the world com
won't overlap world con so I won't have
to one overlap Burning Man so I won't
have to choose so I'll get to do both so
gift economy you know a red diaper baby
comes along and here's 50,000 people
doing no money and they're doing a gift
economy what does that look like um I
guess the thing that I had a hard time
wrapping my head around was the
difference between gifts and barter and
I think everyone has that when you talk
about gift economies two people have
never been they say well what do you
give people and what do they give you in
exchange and this seriously
misunderstands the nature of a gift
economy and it's funny cuz it's infected
the way I think about child-rearing so
one of the things that I often get for
my daughter is a kind of horse trading
she's old she's four and a half you know
and and it probably comes from us
because I'm sure we end up doing it
because everybody ends up doing it if I
give you an Apple will you put your
shoes on so we can go to daycare but
that that always as you know every bad
habit you have comes back into your kids
mouths so I'll put on my shoes if you'll
give me an apple and the thing that I
keep trying to come back to with her is
I will give you an apple because I'm
your father and I love you and we live
in a family together and you get apples
you will put your shoes on because we're
in a family and your job is put your
shoes on these two acts happen nearly
simultaneous but they are not causal
right and it's a it's a difficult it's a
difficult distinction to make but it is
a distinction with a difference right I
mean you know this is this whole notion
of pocket money is something as
something that's not related to chores
chores or chores you do the chores
because you're part of the family we all
do what we can you get your pocket money
because you're part of the family who
all do what we can
if I if people stop buying my books and
my wife was supporting me I wouldn't ask
her for a permission to use the family
checking account because I'm part of the
family unit and we used the checking
account together for the same total you
stay married one checking account yes oh
well
and by the same token my daughter when
she's old enough will get her pocket
money because she gets pocket money and
she'll do chores because she does chores
and I hope that there will be some way
that we can keep those things separate
by Mike there's something as you know
saw its law here might the technology
went wrong they changed my mic and then
I keep knocking this one off after
having this other one taped on so so how
old does your daughter need to be pretty
take her to Burning Man I think that's
more question about us than her it's
it's really a question about the extent
to which would you take her now if you
lived in California what you might I
gather yeah I mean it's possible someday
we might end up living in California we
certainly talk about her lot we've we've
lived here before and for a long time my
wife and I lived here for fourteen
months when when I had the Fulbright at
USC and she was working for the BBC and
certainly it something we think a
brother [ __ ] here and yeah little
brother and the sequel homeland which is
coming out next February both set in San
Francisco a little bit cheek woman so
homeland is the sequel and it's it's set
a couple of years after little brother
and it's it's set in a world in which he
has the young man who's the protagonist
has remind us what the protagonist does
he and little brother that it's it's
about kids who are out playing a
videogame or an alternate reality game
in San Francisco one day when someone
blows up the Bay Bridge and the city
goes into lockdown on the DHS is here
and no one can figure out what's
happened and someone arrests them and
because they're weird and suspicious why
are these school kids walking around
what's going on and instead of
explaining what's gone on they say I'd
like to see a lawyer and that turns out
to be the wrong answer to give in a
condition of emergency for some vote for
some value of wrong answer for for what
certain people seem to think you should
do in the case of an emergency and as a
result they end up being treated very
badly and this is the object lesson they
need to tell them that they that that
what they must do is declare war on the
Department of Homeland Security and
restore the Bill of Rights to San
Francisco and so that's what the rest of
the book is about this this is a young
adult book a young adult novel
it's and the sequel to it is a book
about what happens when the emergency is
not a visible one but a kind of frog
boiling one when when some combination
of economic collapse and austerity and
and and you know the slow monotonic
changes instead of this fast kind of
Shock Doctrine change ends up in this
with getting to almost the same place
and so it opens with with the young
protagonist having been unemployed and
dropped at a university because he
couldn't afford his father's lost his
job at Berkeley after after contractions
and the staffing there he no longer gets
free tuition tuition is going up
tuitions going up he can no longer
afford it
he's especially conscious of the fact
that his student debt will follow him on
to his social security and and he walks
away and and he's trying to find a job
and he's pounding the pavement he can't
find a job as parents can't find a job
everything's contracting he's he's he's
hanging out at the hack space is hanging
out at a noise bridge and he manages to
thank you yeah and he manages to scrimp
and save and and go to Burning Man where
he which incidentally makes my trip to
Burning Man tax deductible he he finds a
job he meets some people including
someone who knows some people who know a
muckraking independent candidate for the
California State Senate who's looking
for a webmaster and he walks into a job
but he walks into a job at the same time
as he walks into holding a giant stash
of government leaks and so he it's about
his tension balancing the fact that he's
got a straight day job working for this
muckraking senator and all of these
leaks and without giving away the whole
story one of the leaks is that an
organization a bit like Blackwater has
spun out and has become private debt
collectors who are buying up subprime
debt and and securitizing it and
collecting on it and they have fanned
out lobbyists to all 50 state houses in
the country with a proposal to pass
state laws on debt collection that will
allow them to attach the assets of
parents of students who've gone back
home after graduating and not finding a
job so it's basically
another way of taking away your house
and it's you know that this is this is
the secret he's sitting on at the same
time as he's working for this muckraking
campaigner so it's a there's there's
lots of occupy style stuff there's lots
of UAVs and quad copters there's lots of
WikiLeaks style stuff there's lots of
there's lots of tour and forward secrecy
Jake Applebaum we're at one of the
afterwards and Aaron Swartz wrote
another is lots of sort of 21st century
politics and and you know next
generation political campaigning and the
kind of stuff we did with SOPA and PIPA
in there and and some ideas that Aaron
had Aaron actually basically wrote a
passage of it for me about what the
future of political organizing and
campaigning might look like in a post
sefa PIPA SOPA world so it's it's it's a
lot like little brother only the next
thing and this is young adult too and
it's young adult too Oceania adults are
very grateful keep it up thank you
thanks
[Music]
[Music]
you